A importância da computação quântica é ao mesmo tempo subestimada
e excessivamente exagerada.
Embora não vá substituir os computadores convencionais,
a inovação quântica representa um novo paradigma computacional.
Os computadores quânticos podem trabalhar em conjunto com a infraestrutura
computacional atual para resolver problemas complexos que antes eram
considerados impraticáveis ou impossíveis.
Isso pode ser uma mudança de paradigma.
Por exemplo, a dificuldade de fatorar números grandes
em seus fatores primos é a base da
criptografia moderna. Para o tamanho dos números usados na
criptografia moderna de chave pública e privada, esse cálculo levaria
o computador convencional mais rápido mais de 300 trilhões de anos.
Para um computador quântico de grande escala trabalhando
com o algoritmo de Shor, esse cálculo poderia levar segundos.
Problemas complexos como esse existem em todos os setores.
As aplicações potenciais para a computação quântica
são vastas.
Os computadores quânticos já estão ficando maiores
e mais capazes,
à medida que buscamos resolver problemas mais complexos.
Desde 2016, a IBM tornou os computadores quânticos acessíveis
ao público por meio de um site com uma interface gráfica que
parece uma partitura musical,
e o kit de desenvolvimento de software Qiskit,
que permite aos usuários programar computadores quânticos.
Cientistas dentro e fora do mundo corporativo
estão realizando experimentos
por meio de portais semelhantes. Eles estão explorando abordagens para química
e problemas de aprendizado de máquina, tentando descobrir
que tipo de perguntas podem fazer
e como vão formular essas perguntas
quando a tecnologia estiver mais avançada. Agora é o
momento certo para os líderes empresariais se prepararem
para o quântico. As condições estão em vigor para experimentar
e expandir essa tecnologia fundamentalmente nova.
As organizações que buscam estar na
vanguarda dessa mudança transformacional vão
conquistar vantagem competitiva. Este treinamento
vai preparar você para começar sua jornada quântica!